c'est une terrible nouvelle qui est
tombée ce matin l'annoncé du décès de
bertrand kamal candidats de la nouvelle
saison de koh lanta sur tf1
il y a deux semaines les téléspectateurs
de la chaîne découvraient pour la toute
première fois son visage aux côtés des
23 autres aventuriers une annonce
tragique qui n'est pas liée à l'
aventure en effet le jeune homme serait
tombé gravement malade il ya quelques
mois
triste hasard du calendrier bertrand
kamal avait décidé de médiatiser ce
combat contre le cancer dans la presse
ça va forcément se savoir
je préfère le dire je n'ai aucune
content avec ça c'est un combat contre
le cancer cette fois qui m'attend les
épreuves ne sont encore pas terminé de
mon côté des déclarations posthumes qui
font froid dans le dos de son côté tf1
et adventure line qui produit koh lanta
ont décidé de réagir dans un communiqué
c'est avec une profonde tristesse que
nous apprenons le décès de bertrand
kamal aventuriers émérite de la tribu de
l'est de koh lanta les cas de terre
actuellement en diffusion
nos pensées vont à sa famille et en
premier lieu a indiqué samir ses parents
sa soeur et son frère alors que les
internautes se posent désormais de
nombreuses questions sur la suite du jeu
tf1 a précisé que la saison lui était
dédié même si nous ne savons pas encore
ce qu'il en sera des prochains épisodes
et si la saison ira à son terme alors
des modifications montel être apportées
koh lanta les quatre ter va-t-elle être
tout simplement annulé
est-ce que koh lanta va être annulée est
ce que la saison va être complètement
remontée est ce qu'il faut arrêter la
saison pour prétendre à toutes ces
questions va d'abord regarder le
portrait bertrand kamel dans l'émission
vous allez voir c'est hyper émouvant
puisque on le voit très joyeux grand
sportif il avait vraiment toutes les
qualités pour faire un très bon candidat
et forcément aussi imaginons que ce soit
bertrand kamel qui ait gagné le jeu on
regarde je m'appelle bertrand kamel je
suis animateur chef de village en eau
des clubs et je suis originaire de dijon
j'ai vécu à dijon jusqu'à mes 22 ans et
ensuite je suis parti à la découverte du
monde en tant qu animateur sportif j'ai
toujours rêvé de travailler des équipes
devenir le leader donc j'ai beaucoup de
sacrifices sim a rapidement permis de
devenir le chef de l'état les gens bien
je te dire que j'ai toujours le smile
toujours la pêche
après j'ai l'habitude de mettre
l'ambiance partout où je vais ça c'est
quelque chose qui me définit vraiment je
met le feu partout où je vais ça me
plaît un peu foufou et c'est alors dans
son porto découvrez aussi qu'il était
vraiment très proche de sa famille il
était très fusionnelle et ses parents
comptable on a revu le vraiment le sujet
et elle son portrait avec les équipes
quand on a su ce qui s'était passé après
vous allez voir c'est extrêmement
émouvant la bourbonne c'est mon chez moi
c'est là que je suis né c'est mon repère
c'est là où je recharge mes batteries
j'ai eu une relation fusionnelle avec
mes parents ce sera avec ma mère ou mon
frère on est très très proches l'un de
l'autre
allez mon fils est parti on va commencer
la séance les deux vous permet dit que
je tiendrais pas deux jours dans le
koh-lanta mais je sais qu'au fond ils
croient en moi et je pense qu'il me dit
ça pour nous booster à lévis
il est hors de question que je rentre au
bout de deux jours je vais te montrer
que tu peux te faire le mans je suis
fier des formes
tu crois ouais je t'aime
on a eu un coup de coeur vraiment pour
ses parents sa mère annick auquel on
pense très très fort ce soit et vraiment
je suis ce garçon c'est vraiment tout ce
qu'on aime voilà sportif simple une
famille vraiment exceptionnel vous a vu
son père qu'il entraîne
alors si vous voulez vous montrer la
personnalité de bertrand kamel dans
l'émission parce que c'était vraiment
quelqu'un vraiment de très bien dans
l'émission qui avait tout le temps la
joie de vivre c'est ce que disait même
tous les autres et surtout en train de
rassurer les autres aventuriers
ça faisait lui un candidat très très
fort dans l'émission ça fait toujours un
candidat denis très fort dans l'émission
puisqu'il sera dans l'émission de demain
regarder la bonne humeur de bertrand cas
mais franchement énonce clairement des
bonnes zones vertes en caméo et pour
rien au monde je l'échangerais dans mon
équipe en alsace va nager
tu vas tu vas on ne lâche rien les verts
les verts c'est la galère ou bats toi
tant qu il n'y a pas de machine doute
pas et si tu continues à te battre comme
ça
il a pas de raison donc faibles y pense
mais fou alors merci emilie d'être avec
nous on va se poser plein de questions
ici les ja on a tous été choqués donc
vous ne savez par la disparition de
bertrand kamel d'autant plus qu'à priori
c'était le favori pour cette saison
ouais c'était le favori déjà les
aventuriers les mettre tous
c'était vraiment unanimes il arrivait
dans le camp c'était vraiment un leader
et il n'était pas trop fort il était
assez fort sa taille il ne s'est pas
imposé comme étant voilà comme étant la
personne qu'il faut absolument éliminer
il était un vrai moteur il était
moniteur donc forcément ça aide beaucoup
et les téléspectateurs on était dingue
dingue dingue
alors on va répondre à toutes vos
questions est-ce que la saison va
continuer normalement
est-ce que déjà pour vous la saison de
koh lanta doit continuer normalement ou
est ce que la production doit arrêter la
saison la pole a donc l'axé on doit
continuer pour vous valez révélé oui je
pense parce que les parents n'ont pas
cessé de dire que c'était le rêve et
c'était lui le disant que c'était son
rêve et que pour lui les legault mêlée
face et c'est comme dit
et le rêve qu'il a qu'il a eu
heureusement avant de partir donc il
faut pas le gommer ce rêve là de ceux de
cet homme là qui qui a enfin vécu
quelque chose qui était très important
pour lui après la production visiblement
dit qu'elle ne touchera pas non plus à
l'aventuré donc il y aura pas de
remontage de l'as de la saison parce que
justement ils veulent la laisser dans
son intégrité dans son intérêt de son
entièreté
et souvenez-vous petit rappel pour ceux
qui ont regardé la finale de la dernière
édition ya eu un mystérieux message à
l'époque puisque on se disait d'eux
qu'ils perdent denis brogniart denis
brogniart avait fait un salut à un
certain samir qui passe qui vivait des
moments difficiles et on savait pas de
qui il parle exactement il ne voulait
pas évidemment mettre en lumière est
pointé du doigt le nom de l'aventurier
en question il avait parlé du papa samir
et il avait tenu des dates déjà à
aggraver mon cas on a l'image c'est vrai
qu'avant on s'était de mourides qui
parlait regarder koh lanta reviendra
bientôt avec de nouveaux aventuriers in
l'énorme nouveauté dès le début je ne
vous en dis pas plus et jour à avoir une
pensée pour salir ce soir et sa famille
qui vivent des moments difficiles on
pense à vous
très belle fin de soirée à tous alors
c'est vrai que bertrand s'était aussi un
sportif dans les épreuves il était très
fort vous a préparé une petite compil
après on vous donnera toutes les
réponses est-ce que la saison va être
arrêté remontée et c'est valérie benaïm
oudinot gilles a des infos également
regarde et bien sûr et me perdre au
camel on laisse
frau l'immunité 3 2
kamel va passer
ok avantages offerts pour l'instant bien
domaine est passé a commencé à
constituer cette fois à l'aide des
planches berton kamel est en avance mais
il ya un ordre à trouver chaque planche
correspondre à un endroit précis alors
la saison donc va suivre son cours
normalement ou pas mais oui bien sûr ils
vont pas y toucher du tout d'ailleurs
alp la société de production a déjà tout
donné à tf1 et là ils ont dit on n'y
touchera pas c'est aussi le souhait de
la famille ce qu'avec la famille
bertrand a été dans la dans l'émission
exactement comme il est dans la vie à
savoir solaire génial adorable et en
fait la famille tu veux que les gens se
souviennent de lui comme ça comme étant
cette personne exceptionnelle qui a fait
cette aventure alors est-ce que vous
pensez que vous il faut annuler la
saison actuellement diffusée gilles
verdez moi je pense qu'il faut l'annuler
vous imaginez un jour si un conseil où
il est mis en difficulté vous imaginez
si à des polémiques autour de lui qui
ont été tournées moi ça me ferait mal je
suis minoritaire je le sais j'ai eu un
candidat aujourd'hui qui m'a expliqué
que les candidats étaient évidemment
bouleversé ils ont un gros poids de ça
pourrit communique un vol que ça
continue mais il n'était pas malade lors
du tournage en octobre novembre
accor s'est déclaré après et auzolle que
ça contient que la production n'était
pas du tout court on a alors au retour
ça s'est déclaré au retour et la
production honnêtement je les critiques
parfois ils ont été exemplaires avec la
famille avec les candidats une grosse
solidarité la famille koh lanta mais moi
ça me choque ça continue mais oui un
hommage sera évidemment rendu demain et
moi j'ai des surprises mettait
effectivement telle somme a confirmé que
l'émission continuerait normalement en
l'état a par l'hommage et qu'il était
évidemment pas question de la nuit
dehors les gens qui appellent téléphone
le souhaitent parc et la saison lui est
dédié bien sûr weekly
surtout qu'on parle d'aider des parents
qui disent que c'était son rêve qui
voulait absolument y participent et
qu'il faut le laisser
mais les parents ne connaissent pas
aussi bien la télé que d'autres
personnes peuvent se rendre compte à
quel point ça peut être dur imaginez il
fait un petit coup de trafalgar à
quelqu'un et ce serait normal
vous imaginez sur les réseaux sociaux la
rafale que les parents se prendrait non
c'est quoi
et ignames actuellement je pense alors
vraiment vous rendez pas il peut y avoir
des travaux
je serais vraiment vous qui se passe que
ça soit jean michel bélot ça c'est le
ghana mais d'une très haute et terrible
annonce que la seule question qu'il faut
se poser c'est qu'est ce qu'il y aurait
voulu lui et je suis pas devin mais
j'ose imaginer que le régler mais que
les images sont diffusées que ses
aventures ne soient pas de souza pas
caviardé que jusqu'au bout on voit dans
son aventure qui lui tenait tant à coeur
j'imagine gilles vous vous êtes là dit
qu'il vous pensez qu'il peut y avoir des
gens sur les réseaux sociaux qui s'en
prennent à bercy sua fait entièrement de
la ville sarde est aussi position mais
la possible non ça va être une immense
chaîne de solidarité sur arcade mais
c'est sait jamais ce qui peut se passer
c'est une émission qui peut être à
l'inter de l'émission cruelle parfois il
ya des polémiques on voit qu'au sein des
régions parfois il ya des clashs cgh
étant à minima qu'on remonte à minima
qu'on remonte dès qu'on les pende je ne
sais pas j'ai pas réussi à savoir dans
quoi on vous le dit c'est aux femmes
jusqu'où il va dans l'émission on ne
sait pas bien sûr imagine ou qu'ils
soient éliminés un jour lors d'un
conseil où ça se déchaîne
c'est pas possible de laisser
s'installer alors en plus d'être sportif
et bon vivant il avait beaucoup d'humour
et l'a26 aussi dans koh lanta c'est
l'hygiène regarde et on peut le
comprendre qu'une douche depuis 5 j
l'habitude je me sens chez moi
le coeur du caire
il faut d'ailleurs dans les cabanes
saisir les 1 face aux autres c'est
d'aller nous la coupe l'appétit d'un
autre côté bertrand car il avait 31 ans
originaire de dijon
c'était l'un des 24 aventuriers les
titulaires d'un bac cinéma audiovisuel
il était animateur et chef de village
dans nos clubs hôtels et il annoncé au
magazine régional le bien public se
battait contre la maladie l'a dit ça va
forcément savoir je préfère le dire
c'était le 28 août
je n'ai aucune honte avec ça c'est un
combat contre le cancer cette fois qui
m'attend les épreuves ne sont pas encore
terminés de mon côté je suis tombé
malade après l' aventure
je suis en plein combat contre la
maladie sur facebook il a dit même si je
n'ai pas l'habitude d'étaler ma vie
intime sur les réseaux je me dois de
vous expliquer mon silence depuis
plusieurs mois vous qui avec qui j'ai eu
la chance de partager des moments
uniques et inoubliables
vous qui m'avez temps donné durant
toutes ces années tous ces souvenirs
c'est fou rire ces moments de bonheur
simple auquel je m'attache aujourd'hui
pour me battre plus fort que jamais
contre la maladie
ouais ben [ __ ] de maladie ça n'arrive
pas qu'aux autres si je vous dis ça
c'est que cela fait maintenant des mois
que je me batte jour et nuit et j'ai
besoin de votre force
plus que jamais et emilie oui parce
qu'en fait ils l'avaient annoncé bien
avant de faire cette interview
parce qu'il était très suivie sur les
réseaux sociaux parce qu'il faisait
plein de petites activités
du côté de dijon moi je tiens à préciser
quand même qu'avant de faire koh lanta
ils ont énormément de tests physiques
ils voient des médecins ils font un truc
vraiment drastique pire qu à l'insep et
donc personne n'avait détecté ça et même
lui même sa famille ne le savais pas
donc c'est important de rappeler que non
il n'est pas parti en étant malade c'est
après qu'il a deux choix alors sur
twitter parce que gilles et kelly sur
les réseaux sociaux sachez le et un a
plein qui disent pas sûr qu'il faut
continuer à diffuser définition et
beaucoup aussi qu'il pense qu'il faut
arrêter la diffusion par respect pour la
famille comment on pourrait regarder koh
lanta en sachant qu'une des personnes
dedans est décédé à vous prendre les
responsabilités
allez-vous faire de l'audience sur un
programme ou un homme qui a perdu la vie
où allez vous respectez la famille les
proches et arrêter le programme j'espère
que tf1 va des programmes et cette
saison de koh lanta par respect pour la
famille ouais je sais mais est ce qu'ils
vont continuer à diffuser koh lanta si
oui ça va être dur pour la famille douar
son fils à la télé de son vivant il
faudra annuler la suite de koh lanta
mais là on va regarder koh lanta en
sachant que bertrand kamel un des plus
adorables est décédé ça me brise donc là
et parents ont répondu la thur oui c'est
ça en fait où moi je comprends votre
point de vue mais juste un moment donné
il forcé par mon point de vue c'est pour
nous
les celui de kelly et celui de certains
télé certains internautes il faut
respecter le choix de la famille c'est
quand même eux qui ont le dernier mot
et si eux considèrent que c'est une
bonne chose de garder les missions et de
ne pas y toucher et de laisser bertrand
kamal comme arjen que si bien on a pas
on n'a pas y toucher en fait alors j'ai
une question dans ces cas là est ce que
la famille a eu le droit de regarder les
épisodes c'est ça la vraie question
parce que s'ils ont le droit de regarder
les épisodes et que ça leur convient ya
pas de soucis mais imagine qu'il se
passe quelque chose et que là ça leur
brise le coeur moi je suis pour protéger
la facture risque majeur oui mais je
pense qu'en rentrant il a dû un peu
aussi exploiter raconte et comment ça
s'était pas sur wii mais le montage on
sait comment c'est denis bruguier proche
de la fin connais bien les rouages hu a
appelé la famille notamment le papa il
entretient des très bons très très bonne
relation pour lui expliquer la voiture
de son fils à la chaîne a chuté avec
tout le monde d'avoir su voir continuer
la diffusion aujourd'hui réunir et
discuter c'est sûr non moi effectivement
je pense que j ai et kelly on peut pas
finalement balayé d'un revers de manche
comme ça la volonté et de la famille et
bertrand sous prétexte du respect qu'on
pourra alors et je pense que malgré tout
même si un directeur ce parce que le
monde et art et il y aura toujours des
spurs il y aura toujours des gens
absolument sordide ce sera forcément
balayé par la vague d'amour
il faut espérer que je mens revanche moi
je pense quand même que malgré tout la
production devrait faire peut-être un
geste dans la mesure où le gagnant de
koh lanta a gagné son mille cent mille
euros
pourquoi pas symboliquement par rapport
à cette édition un peu particulière
donnée à une association de lutte contre
le cancer faire un geste quelque chose
comme ça je pense que la prod pourrait
fermer les son vélo et vous allez au
gagnant c'est à lui de voir les bains
alors à ce moment-là je sais pas
j'aimerais qu'ils donnent dans lé dinh
par un couple parfait qui est une
émission qui ne sert à rien met donc à
ce moment-là il devrait peut-être donné
sa version qui sert à quelque chose non
pas que le juge pourrait pour la
géraldine kelly et moi on ne balaie pas
la pensée de la famille d'un revers de
manche au contraire simplement qu'on
n'est pas dans une fiction là c'est un
film ou un acteur est décédée dix ans
après owen film c'est du réel cet
homme-là qui était magnifique c'était le
leader charismatique de la saison de koh
lanta de l'avis de tous ceux que j'ai
eus aujourd'hui mais j'y tiens meneur
d'hommes sachant dit d'un merveilleux un
aventurier d'enfer il a toutes les
qualités on va le regarder en sachant
qu'il est mort alors je trouve que c'est
extrêmement
jurado agile que pendant que tous ces
mois de souffrance de douleur il a pas
raconté à ses parents comment ça ça ne
l'est pas c'est qu'elle a et c sont
recensées de la région connaît pas le
montage qu'on est bêtes tout ce qui va
se passer dans on peut pas savoir
et justement c'est un jeu et la mort
c'est pas un jeu mais ils vont veiller à
leur âge et à denis brogniart qui a
réagi il a dit je suis dévastée par le
décès de bertrand cavalerie hier soir il
avait 30 ans je les ai connus comme
aventuriers de koh lanta et je les
aimais comme un ami ensuite un être cher
avec qui j'ai partagé tant d'instants
privilégiés
il m'avait ému aux fidji m'a bouleversée
après il m'a impressionné par son
courage son mental sa tendresse et son
altruisme un grand monsieur un mec en or
un aventurier formidable sa vie a été
courte mais si riche et intense faite
d'amour de joie de générosité honorons
la mémoire de cet homme si bon je pense
à sa maman annick à son papa samira sa
soeur et à son frère qui l'ont entouré
avec tant d'amour jusqu'au bout mon bk
je garde pour toujours ton sourire tes
yeux pétillants nos moments quotidiens
quand c'était si dur je ne t'oublierai
jamais je t'aime oui parce qu'en plus on
a tendance à croire que une fois que les
caméras sont éteintes et batman ce
schéma là en l'occurrence denis
brogniart ils étaient extrêmement
proches et des parents et de bertrand
kamal vont ils étaient là dans les
derniers instants dans les dernières
semaines il a vraiment suivi surtout que
lui l'a vécue dans sa vie personnelle il
a perdu quelqu'un de cette terrible
maladie
donc voilà il faut aussi penser je sais
bien sûr à la famille et aux proches et
en l'occurrence de nice était vraiment
pas fin c'était vraiment un ami
extrêmement proches
depuis cette aventure alors il ya une
question qui arrive si bertron km est
arrivé en finale et qui sort vainqueur
comment il est comment ça se passe
est-ce que alors oui mais en fait c'est
une c'est universel c'est dans la loi
c'est pour tous les jeux en l'occurrence
si jamais ils gagnent les 100000 euros
ça revient à ses ayants droit à savoir
les parents ma femme et ma mariés donc à
sa famille est ce assez pour tous les
jeux en france ma spécifique à kolontar
édition donc doit-on arrêté la saison de
koh lanta raymond moi je moi d'abord
quand j'ai vu ça je me suis dit de 31
ans je me suis on est vraiment rien sur
cette terre ça peut arriver à n'importe
qui comme l'a dit et je moi je pense
surtout à ses parents à lui et gilles a
dit quelque chose d'intéressant il a dit
les candidats personne n'était au
courant donc là avec la saison elle
s'est déroulée normalement donc la
version move personne n'est au courant
n'y aura pas de traitement de faveur de
quoi que ce soit et elle et ses parents
doivent être fier de lui et bien sûr
qu'il faut diffuser la saison
bien sûr que cet essai est son rêve
puisqu'il a regardé
nantes avant d'y participer parce qu'on
va pas à koh lanta sans avoir regardé
les autres c'est qui fait cette émission
il a dû qui fait la faire et moi je mets
à la place de les parents la famille un
dernier hommage au relais sont la saison
comme elle est là et soyons fiers de ce
café bertrand kamal et ses parents
peuvent être fiers parce qu'il a été au
bout du bout de ses rêves voilà moi je
suis trucks ont toutes un physicien jean
michel ce qu'il y a raison il faut faire
attention quand même il peut y avoir des
choses dans chaque épisode lequel on ne
pensera toujours atteint 10 minutes
maintenant elle est d'accord avec toi
vas y on veut soyons fous imaginons
rêvons qu'il ait gagné mais sa secte en
mai on annulait diffusion donc tout ce
que laisse à ses ayants droit ne
toucherait pas large en seconde touche
avant tout les mêmes sans parler
d'argent et notre angoisse badar j'ai
quand l'émission est diffusée est serré
serré le jeu le jeu est arrêté avant que
la turquie a gagné et mis son passé qui
gagne rien c'est ben oui c'est vrai j'ai
donc illégales même jean pierre pernaut
lui ont rendu un hommage et un 16 heures
de tf1 donc été une immense émotion ce
matin à tf1 je pense bien sûr d'abord à
denis brogniart et à toute l'équipe de
kolontar on a en effet appris la mort
d'un des candidats de l'aventuré qu'on
est en train de suivre en ce moment
bertrand kamal vous le connaissez nous
épate avec son sourire sa bonne humeur
sa joie de vivre
mais après le tournage il a découvert
une terrible maladie un cancer qui l'a
emporté très vite il avait 30 ans tout
le reste de la saison lui sera dédiée
bien sûr dès demain soir et on pense
énormément à sa famille et à ses parents
c'est le style plus belle le candidat
que j'avais aujourd'hui il me disait
demain je vais regarder avec des
frissons
je vais être bouleversé là on est sur
l'émotion mais la semaine d'après on
sera plus sur l'émotion on aura déjà un
regard un peu plus distanciée y aurait
eu la semaine et moi j'ai peur
exactement comme kelly qu'à ce moment là
les gens n'est plus dans ce recul cet
amour pour bertrand dont on a rêvé riton
arrêt là ça peut être violent qu'on
appelle moi je mets moi je pense pour
vous enfoncer la famille et moi remonter
tous les épisodes heures de route et
tous les épisodes qui ont longtemps
oui parce que wanda pascale imaginer
qu'à une polémique qui gagne une épreuve
même s'ils gagnent une épreuve
on va vous triste excusez moi on va voir
une personne magnifique je vais céder
qui gagnent l'épreuve
mais jean-michel fait quand même j'ai
pas une fiction c'est quand même
perturbant il est décédé on va le voir
gagner des et prospère baiser
mais moi je suis pas noir je sens que
pour ses parents au contraire ils vont
être encore plus confiance qu'au
contraire ça va déjà franchement pour sa
famille oui ça va prolonger un peu le
rêve de 4 ans 15e ajouté je pense moi si
je suis au ps si j'étais si j'étais
voilà le papa de bertrand kamel j'aurais
aimé le voir moi dans son ambiance si je
sais que c'était son m
j'aurais aimé le voir aller jusqu'au
bout et voir ce qu'il a fait dans cette
aventure je suis désolé mais vendredi il
doit diriger rendez vous avec cette
dernière
on dit souvent parfois on ne veut pas
voir les derniers instants parce qu'on
n'a pas revus garder une image affaibli
de quelqu'un qu'on a aimés avec un
masque mortuaire où quelqu'un de
diminuer là on va il va voi la famille
c'est puisqu'elle l'a souhaité va voir
son fils son frère dans la flamboyance
en train d'être heureux en train d
amuser en train de vivre est gardée
comme image une image d'un garçon qui
réalise son rêve si on se retrouve que
deux derniers tomes dernière image
je comprends qu'ils aient envie de voir
cette merveille alors on vous pose la
question aviez tout ce qu'on a lancé
vous parce que ça a réagi énormément
énormément là dessus je vous le dis oui
jean michel aulas la première chose
évidemment après là l'émotion causée par
sa mort c'est vrai que c'est un candidat
qui avait absolument fantastique je ne
le connaissais pas mais moi je suis j'ai
pensé une sorte de malédiction sur ce
jeu quand même terrible choix après
après la mort d'un des candidats le
suicide du médecin de l'émission alors y
agira gradins qui l'exercice us générés
quitter en 2013
giresse du matin un candidat de 25 ans
qui a trouvé la mort pendant une épreuve
de tir à la corde il a conduit là il
avait succombé à une crise cardiaque
regardez c'était ça c'était terrible
aussi en 2013 il venait à peine de
commencer le jeu après avoir sauté d'un
bateau avec les autres concurrents pour
rejoindre denis brogniart sur l'île
gerald de babin participe à la première
épreuve du jeu celle du tir à la corde
et c'est après celui ci que le jeune
homme de 25 ans se plaint de crampes aux
bras
le médecin décide de l'évacuer c'est au
cours de son transfert qu'il fait
plusieurs arrêts cardiaques
le dernier fatale se produira quelques
minutes après son arrivée à l'hôpital il
ya quelques minutes
annonçant le rapatriement de toutes les
équipes de production et la raie bien
entendu instantanée du jeu
une enquête est alors ouverte pour
homicide involontaire alors c'est vrai
que j'ai raté ma main voilà c'est en
2013 et quelques jours plus tard
l'émission avait avait renoncé le
suicide du médecin démission thierry
costes a donc cet angle et après l'année
suivante je crois la nation de quelqu'un
il s'était en 2018 alors quelques années
plus tard il ya l'histoire de l'est
l'agression sexuelle après les
agressions ces grands médias qui a
arrêté le jeu en place et la maintenance
et un candidat qui meurent pendant la
diffusion du jeu c'est une sorte c'est
comme un peu la mode élections tout en
bande ka ba oui mais je trouve ça fait
beaucoup quand même
et douze de ses chats d'or se passe bien
que fait sa mère trop kamel c'est
jusqu'à beaucoup de gens qui veulent
vivre leur rêve le rêve c'est de
participer à koh lanta je vois des gens
dans la rue je vous le dis la seule
émission à laquelle il a dit qu'il me
parlait me dit cyril est ce que tu
connais quelqu'un sur koh lanta j'ai
vraiment envie de participer
c'est l'émission qui fait rêver
l'émission la plus forte aujourd'hui de
la télévision française donc forcément
aussi il ya un coup de projecteur qui
n'est pas le même que sur d'autres
émissions forcément c'est normal qu'on
n'en parle plus et une malédiction il ya
eu d'autres je vois là où il ya des
drames malheureusement f1 sur tf1 drop
zone
ces mêmes raisons mais alors mais c'est
ma chère arrêté mais qu'un vague de
mettre la faute sur tf1 je mangeais
grave et pourquoi tf1
parce que c'est eux qu'il faut les plus
contrôlées surnommé c'est sûr c'est sûr
que dans mot de passe il va pas avoir
d'autre après dans l'éclusé ma vie c'est
une addiction c'est pas vrai ça nous
pousse à une malédiction jean-michel je
pense que c'est ce que c'est la chaîne
qui produit les plus grosses émissions
donc forcément les tiens express et a
pas eu d'accident complexe à la presse
et remis à chaque fois oui
cette fois la même production koh lanta
saison que j'ai bien lu hier matin
finition
c'est vrai qu'il est en fait que tu
regardes sur la longueur mais oui voilà
c'est la vie c'est la vie n'a dit hélas
ça n'a rien à voir avec koh lanta encore
une fois alors justement il ya des gens
qui disent il faut laisser des émissions
telles quelles voilà qu'elle était
montée ça va être difficile pour la
famille 10 mai est-ce qu'il faut arrêter
la seconde contest qui font remonter les
émissions dites nous et c'est vrai qu'on
a on a envie de savoir parfaitement la
cie bertron on aurait en un mois
bertrand qu'il aille au bout minuit et
midi outre le fait que la saison va lui
être dédié
est ce que tu sais si par exemple il va
y avoir un contexte particulier pour la
programmation vendredi alors numéro est
meilleur un message d denis brogniart
car il va y avoir quelque chose de
particulier alors en fait ils ont fait
des bruits
une toute la journée on fait des
réunions toute la journée pour essayer
de trouver la meilleure façon possible
en accord avec la famille faire le plus
bel hommage en vrai vous juste pour
réagir sur ce que disent gillet kelly
mois pour moi le plus bel hommage qu'on
puisse faire à bertrand kamal c'est
justement de continuer cette diffusion
parce que lui ne voulait et qu'il a eu
des mois pour le dire à sa famille bien
sûr ils imaginaient peut-être ne soit
une vidéo sur un bandeau
le problème c'est que ça et que c'est
une situation délicate où on est
effondré que ce soit chez alp chez tf1
donc aux dernières nouvelles il était
encore en train de réfléchir à comment
faire le plus bel hommage que celui de
maman bertrand kamal alors qu'elle y
cocon la famille dit qu'elle a envie de
le voir vendredi
est ce que vous venez sur sur le fait
que vous aimeriez que ce soit qui soit
vraiment que l'émission soit remontée ou
pas du tout moi je préférais je
préférais que l'émission soit remonté je
préférerais pas qu'elle passe comme ça
parce que si on me dit que la famille
n'a pas vu les images je suis désolé
mais ça peut être trop dangereux pour
eux moi je pense plus à leur protection
à eux et aux retombées on connaît pas
les retombées quand on ne sait pas et
qu' on laisse place au hasard je pense
que c'est trop dangereux
d'ailleurs la question il ya eu des
brainstormings effectivement la question
va se poser de semaine en semaine et je
vous le dis bon on dit pas ce qui va se
passer et puis on sait pas tout mais si
un jour il est éliminé
vous imaginez toutes là toute la journée
comment tf1 va essayer de gérer ça je
suis sûr que là ils vont secouer la
senelec chinois qu'ils soient éliminés
lors d'un marseille ouais je n'irai pas
là s'était dit persuadé que la décision
ça pourrait être
on annule cette élimination mais non et
ce sera possible voire éliminer mais
pour donner les codes de la hauteur
remontée faut trouver une solution c'est
pour ça que moi je milite pour
l'annulation je reste sur ma position
serait livré juste imaginer là ils sont
dans un contexte où il peut se passer
des choses c'est une émission il ya des
coups dans le dos y ait une émission une
limande cd et on sait pas comment il va
évoluer son personnage on sait pas d
action qui va avoir
vous imaginez le monde cruel qui assure
les réseaux sociaux vous imaginez les
gens comment ils sont cruels mais même
avec la mort et s'était vu des menaces
de mort g g avec la mort ils sont cruels
paru on l'a dit qu'il y avait quelqu'un
crée disparu et j'embrasse talent on a
dit qu apparemment bon il ya du temps
qui s'est passé après la saison donc je
pense qu'il en a parlé à ses parents
mes parents ont validé apparemment que
ça continue donc moi je pensais mais je
pense qu'ils sont au courant puisqu'il
leur a raconté tout ça donc si les
parents validé je pense qu'ils veulent
voir quand on est le problème à l'envers
vous voulez qu'on monte vous voulez
qu'on triche là on va pas tricher c'est
parce qu'elle vous voulez quand on
regarde un candidat que c'est pas vrai
que les pépins aux dires du célèbre
est-ce que c'est pas bref moi je vote
l'arrêt c'est un dash de tarass boulba m
je veux qu'on respecte tel quel ce mec a
eu le courage d'aller à berlin qui a été
repris dans le casting comme on sait
comment c'est dur il a réalisé son rêve
c'est ça un dernier au revoir c'est une
dernière tournée je veux que ça reste
comme tel et cylia goldorak et dora
l'exploratrice et oui oui qui
l'insultent sur twitter et bakkies avec
sofia je vous le dis si chrome jura pas
une insulte et un oriental tranquille je
vais vous dire une chose pour moi la
limite ce serait même une deuxième mort
pour lui si on l'effacé se pose bien sûr
je suis là c'est parce qu'il aurait
voulu et non non non non
et le bonheur de ses parents voilà bien
sûr une forme très beau gentil et tout
ça quoi qu'il arrive par la suite on
sentait fia joli départ ce serait une
deuxième mort de l'enlever vous fier à
votre chien au coeur des prix à la pompe
a trait à que je connais tous en plus
les codes de koh lanta on veut
certainement pas en faire un saint en
fait on va rentrer ce qu'ils voulaient
un compétiteur on le voit et je pense
qu'il veut qu'on le voit dans cette
aventure bien sûr en train de se battre
en train de faire les épreuves comme les
autres mais en train de montrer ce qu'il
est capable de faire
c'est vrai que je pense que c'est ce
qu'on va voir sa famille
et puis même s'il ya des gens qui sont
assez fous ou cruels ou ce que tu veux
ou pas ou psychopathe pour critiquer
quelqu'un qui est décédé pendant le
combat urbain alors donné raison en
changeant la démission sans armes a pas
avoir peur de leur réaction est à genoux
en sang ce n'est pas sa famille a donné
raison à des jeux vidéo et est
maintenant les parents veulent vraiment
qu'on voit bien je suis content de mes
temps il cette personne là c'est celle
qui a battu utah
bien sûr les parents veulent payer des
millions milliers de français qui
millions de français qui le découvrent
qu'ils étaient berline à malle et en
l'occurrence en continuant est passé sur
le web on cesse comme sont tous les
congés aux côtés de josé jolie histoire
les bains si les parents c'est pas chez
les parents qui décident pour voir
décision est ce qu'on peut voir le
sondage si oui 18%
nous attendrons d'un des deux fois mais
ça regarde